de dire qu'en tant qu'américains on devrait plus se soucier des américains
que des autres.
En général les gens sont influencés
par un sentiment de loyauté, de solidarité, de fierté, de patriotisme
envers leur pays ou leur groupe ethnique.
Sans lien politique, beaucoup sont fiers d'être americains
ils préfèrent les américains aux autres.
Les habitants d'autres pays réagissent pareil pour leur pays
et nous faisons de même pour notre groupe ethnique
Certains ici peuvent rejeter ça.
Certains peuvent être cosmopolites
au point de penser que l'ethnicité, la nationalité
ne devraient pas avoir d'influence morale.
Mais même ceux là admettent
que le groupe tend à tirer à soi
des gens par rapport à leurs amis et familles,
leurs proches,
et alors même vous, faites une distinction entre eux et nous.
Cette distinction est plutôt naturelle,
et souvent plutôt morale, mais elle peut aussi mal tourner.
et c'est une partie des recherches menées par le brillant psychologue Henri Tajfel.
Tajifel es né en Pologne en 1919.
Il est allé étudier en France car,
étant Juif, il ne pouvait pas étudier à la fac en Pologne.
Il s'est alors engagé dans l'armée française pendant
la 2nde guerre mondiale.
On l'a capturé et emmené dans un camp de prisonniers de guerre
et c'était un moment terrifiant pour lui
car si l'on découvrait sa religion
il pouvait être envoyé dans un camp de concentration,
où il n'aurait pas survécu.
En fait, quand on l'a relâché à la fin de la guerre,
la plupart de ses proches étaient morts.
Il a participé à beaucoup d'activités.
Il a aidé les orphelins de guerre.
Mais son intérêt de longue date portait sur la science des préjugés,
et donc quand une bourse prestigieuse s'est ouverte sur les stéréotypes,
il y a postulé et il l'a remporté
et il a commencé une carrière incroyable.
Ce qui a débuté sa carrière,
c'est l'idée que la façon dont la plupart de gens
pensait à l'holocauste était incorrecte.
Beaucoup de gens, voire la plupart à l'époque, considéraient l'holocauste
comme la représentation d'un défaut tragique des allemands
une sorte de faiblesse génétique, le signe d'une personnalité autoritaire.
Tajfel a rejeté cette idée.
Il a dit que ce que nous voyons dans l'holocauste
est juste une exagération
des processus psychologiques normaux
qui existent chez n'importe qui.
Et pour approfondir cela, il a réalisé une série d'études
auprès d'adolescents britanniques.
Au cours de l'une de ses études,
il a posé toutes sortes de questions aux adolescents
et au vu de leurs réponses, il a conclu :
"J'ai regardé vos réponses et à partir de cela,
j'ai déterminé que vous étiez--", il a dit ça à une moitié des ados,
"un amateur de Kandinsky, vous aimez son oeuvre."
Ou : "Vous êtes un amateur de Klee, vous aimez son oeuvre."
C'était entièrement truqué.
L'artiste n'avait rien à voir avec leurs réponses.
Ils n'avaient probablement pas entendu parler des artistes.
Il les a juste divisés arbitrairement en deux groupes.
Mais ce qu'il a découvert, c'est l'importance de ces catégories.
Et plus tard, quand il a donné de l'argent aux gens,
ils préféreraient le donner aux membres de leur propre groupe
qu'à ceux de l'autre groupe.
Pire, ils s'étaient surtout attachés
à la mise en place d'une différence entre leur groupe et les autres,
ils donneraient donc à leur propre groupe
si cela signifiait qu'ils donneraient encore moins à l'autre groupe.
Cette préférence semble se révéler très tot.
Ma collègue et femme, Karen Wynn, à Yale
a mené des études auprès de bébés
qu'elle expose à des peluches
qui ont différentes préférences alimentaires.
Par exemple, l'une aime les haricots verts
et l'autre aime les crackers.
On analyse les préférences alimentaires des bébés,
et typiquement ils préfèrent les crackers.
Mais est-ce que leur préférence influence la façon
dont ils se comportent avec les peluches? Oui, beaucoup.
En général, ils préfèrent celle qui a les même goûts alimentaires,
et pire, ils préfèrent même les peluches
qui punissent celles qui ont des goûts différents.
(Rires)
On retrouve ce clivage psychologique 'eux/nous' tout le temps.
Que ce soit en débats politiques, entre des groupes idéologiquement opposés.
C'est même poussé à l'extrême en cas de guerre,
où 'les autres' ne sont pas seulement lésés
mais déshumanisés,
à l'instar des Nazis considérant les Juifs
comme de la vermine ou des poux,
ou les américains comparant les Japonais à des rats.
Les clichés peuvent aussi mal tourner.
Ils sont souvent rationnels et utiles,
mais parfois ils ne le sont pas,
ils donnent les mauvaises solutions
et à d'autres moments ils entraînent des conséquences immorales.
Le cas qui a été le plus examiné
est celui de la race.
Une étude fascinante avant l'élection de 2008
avait analysé à quel point
les candidats étaient associés aux États-Unis
comme dans une association inconsciente avec le drapeau américain.
Dans l'une de leurs études ils comparaient Obama et McCain,
et le résultat montrait que McCain était considéré comme plus américain,
Et d'un certain côté, les gens n'en sont pas trop surpris.
McCain est un héros de guerre,
et beaucoup de gens diraient même
qu'il représente plus qu'Obama l'histoire américaine.
Mais ils comparaient aussi Obama
à Tony Blair, l'ancien premier ministre britannique,
et ils se sont aperçus
que Blair était aussi considéré plus américain qu'Obama,
même si les sujets comprenaient clairement qu'il n'est pas du tout américain.
En fait, ils se fiaient surtout à la couleur de sa peau.
Ces stéréotypes et préjugés ont des conséquences sur le monde réel
à la fois subtiles et très importantes.
Dans une étude récente, des chercheurs ont posté des pubs sur eBay
pour la vente de cartes de base-ball.
Certains étaient tenues par des mains blanches,
d'autres par des mains noires.
Les cartes étaient les mêmes.
Celles des mains noires ont reçu des offres inférieures
à celles des mains blanches.
Dans une recherche de l'université de Stanford
des psychologues ont étudié le cas de personnes
condamnées pour le meurtre d'une personne blanche.
Il s'avère que, à situation totalement égale,
il est plus probable d'être exécuté
si on ressemble à l'homme de droite qu'à l'homme de gauche,
et c'est essentiellement parce que
l'homme de droite a plus l'air d'être noir
plus typiquement afro-américain,
et ça influence apparemment les gens au moment de décider de sa sentence.
Alors maintenant qu'on le sait, comment lutter contre cela?
Il y a différentes façons.
L'une consiste à faire appel aux réactions émotionnelles des gens,
à leur empathie,
on le fait souvent par des histoires.
Par exemple, si vous êtes un parent liberal
et que vous voulez pousser vos enfants
à croire au mérite des familles non-traditionnelles
vous pourriez leur offrir "Heather a deux mamans"
Si vous êtes conservateur, vous offririez plutôt celui-là:
"A l'aide! Des libéraux sous mon lit!"
Mais en général, une histoire peut transformer
de sombres inconnus en individus qui comptent,
et l'idée que l'on tient à des gens
lorsque l'on les reconnait en tant qu'individus,
est une idée apparue au cours de l'Histoire.
D'ailleurs, on dit que Staline aurait dit,
"Un mort est une tragédie, un million de morts, c'est statistique."
Mère Teresa disait,
"Si je regarde la foule je n'agirai jamais si je regarde une personne, je le ferai."
Les psychologues ont étudié cela.
Par exemple, dans une étude
on a donné aux sujets une liste de faits à propos d'une crise
et on a observé combien ils donneraient
pour résoudre cette crise,
un autre groupe n'avait pas la liste,
mais on leur parlait d'un individu,
en donnant un nom et un visage,
et il se trouve que ceux là ont donné bien plus que les autres.
Tout cela ce n'est pas un secret
pour ceux qui font du bénévolat.
En général, on ne bombarde pas les gens de faits et de statistiques
On leur montre plutôt des visages, des personnes.
Il est possible qu'en élargissant notre sympathie à un individu,
cela se propage au groupe auquel la personne appartient.
Voici Harriet Beecher Stowe.
L'histoire, peut-être inventée, raconte que le président Lincoln l'avait invitée
à la maison blanche pendant la guerre civile
et lui avait dit:
"Alors c'est toi la femme à l'origine de cette grande guerre."
il parlait de "La Case de l'oncle Tom."
Ce livre n'est pas une grande oeuvre philosophique
ou théologique ou peut-être même littéraire,
mais ce qu'il fait bien
c'est d'aider les gens à se mettre à la place d'autres
alors qu'ils ne le feraient pas autrement,
à se mettre à la place des esclaves.
Et ça a très bien pu être le catalyseur pour le grand changement social.
Plus récemment à propos d'Étas-Unis
au cours des dernières décennies, on a des raisons de croire
que des programmes comme "The Cosby Show",
ont changé l'attitude des Américains envers les Afro-Américains,
et que des programmes comme "Will et Grace" et "Modern Family"
ont modifié les comportements envers les homosexuels.
Il n'est pas exagéré de dire
que le grand catalyseur du changement moral aux Etats-Unis
a été le sitcom.
Il ne s'agit pas seulement d'émotions.
Je terminerai en faisant appel à la raison.
Dans ce livre merveilleux "The Better Angels of Our Nature,"
Steven Pinker soulève que
l'Ancien Testament dicte d'aimer son prochain
le Nouveau Testament dicte d'aimer son ennemi,
mais je n'aime ni l'un ni l'autre, sincèrement,
mais je ne veux pas les tuer.
Je comprends mes obligations envers eux,
mais mes sentiments pour eux, mes convictions morales,
et la façon dont je me comporte,
ne sont pas basés sur l'amour.
Ils sont basés sur une compréhension des droits de l'homme,
que leur vie vaut pour eux autant que la mienne pour moi.
Et pour soutenir cela, il raconte une histoire du philosophe Adam Smith,
et je veux la raconter aussi,
mais je vais l'adapter un peu à nos temps modernes.
Adam Smith commence en vous demandant d'imaginer la mort de milliers de gens
et d'imaginer que ces gens se trouvent dans un pays que vous ne connaissez pas.
Cela peut-être en Chine, en Inde ou dans un pays africain.
Et Smith demande comment vous répondriez?
Et vous diriez que c'est dommage,
et vous continueriez votre vie.
Si vous ouvriez le NY Times en ligne, ou autre,
et que vous découvriez cela, ce qui arrive souvent,
on vaque à ses occupations.
Mais imaginez maintenant, nous dit Smith, vous découvriez que demain
vous vous apprêtez à vous faire couper le petit doigt.
Cela vous importerait beaucoup.
Vous passeriez la nuit debout à y réfléchir.
Alors cela soulève la question :
Est-ce que vous sacrifieriez des milliers de vies
pour sauver votre petit doigt?
Répondez à cela dans votre tête,
mais Smith répond, absolument pas,
quelle idée horrible.
Et cela soulève donc la question comme Smith l'exprime,
"Si nos sentiments passifs sont presque toujours
aussi sordides et égoïstes,
pourquoi nos principes actifs
devrait souvent être aussi généreux et nobles?"
La réponse de Smith est :
"C'est la raison, les principes, la conscience qui nous influencent
pour surmonter la plus présomptueuse de nos passions
qui est que nous sommes un parmi d'autres
en aucun cas meilleur que n'importe lequel autre"
Cette dernière partie est ce qu'on décrit souvent comme le principe d’impartialité.
Et ce principe est présent dans toutes les religions du monde,
dans toutes les versions de la règle d'or,
et toutes les philosophies morales du monde
qui se différencient mais
partagent le présupposé qu'on devrait juger la morale
d'un point de vue plus ou moins impartial.
La meilleur explication de cette idée
est à mon avis, non pas celle d'un théologien ou d'un philosophe,
mais celle de Humphrey Bogart à la fin du film "Casablanca"
Alors, alerte spoiler, il dit à son amante
qu'ils doivent se séparer pour le bien de tout le monde,
et il dit --je ne ferai pas l'accent--
il lui dit : "Je n'ai rien de magnanime mais avouons que nos petits problèmes
n'ont pas grande importance dans ce monde en folie."
Notre raison pourrait nous faire surmonter nos passions.
Notre raison pourrait nous motiver à montrer plus d'empathie,
à écrire un livre comme "La Case de l'oncle Tom"
ou à lire un tel livre,
et notre raison peut nous motiver à créer des coutumes, des tabous et des lois
qui nous empêcheront d'agir de façon impulsive
quand, en tant qu'êtres rationnels on devrait se sentir obligés.
C'est ça une constitution.
Une constitution c'est une chose qu'on a installé dans le passé
qui s'applique à présent et qui dit,
qu'indépendamment du désir de réélire un président populaire une troisième fois,
indépendamment du désir
des américains blancs de rétablir l'esclavage,
on ne le peut pas.
Nous nous sommes limités nous-mêmes.
Et nous nous sommes aussi liés d'une autre manière.
On sait, que lorsque l'on doit choisir quelqu'un
pour un travail ou pour une récompense,
on est fortement influencé par sa race,
on est influencé par son genre,
ou par le charme de la personne,
et parfois on dirait : "C'est comme ça que ça doit être."
Mais d'autres fois, on dirait : "C'est injuste."
Alors pour lutter contre cela,
non seulement on doit faire plus d'efforts
mais on doit surtout construire des situations dans lesquelles
on ne peut pas être influencés par d'autres sources d'informations.
Ainsi, beaucoup d'orchestres auditionnent les musiciens derrière un écran
afin qu'ils aient seulement l'information importante
et pas tout le reste.
Je pense que les idées reçues et les préjugés
illustrent une dualité fondamentale de la nature humaine.
On a des intuitions, des instincts et des émotions
qui influencent nos jugements et nos actes,
pour le bien et le mal,
mais nous sommes aussi capables de mener une réflexion rationnelle
et une préparation intelligente
que l'on peut utiliser pour, dans certains cas,
accélérer et alimenter nos émotions,
et d'autres fois les apaiser.
C'est ainsi que la raison nous aide à créer un monde meilleur.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)